there we go thank
you
okay let's see how I going to set this
St
um me
see you
guys okay okay go like that
so guys I had some uh some members of
the LDS church come in and
uh while I was live streaming so this is
pretty cool I I I'll get right back to
you wait um Pokemon how how much time do
you
have
um no I can I can uh no problem no
problem you can uh take your time all
right for sure for sure so how how much
time do you guys have like 10ish minutes
10 about 10 minutes okay yeah that's
fine so okay so did uh did they did they
catch you guys up on on what um on what
we're uh what we were talking about last
time I don't know okay okay yeah okay
for sure yeah so as you guys can see I'm
I do this so like uh I was literally
just having a live stream with uh with
Muslims and yes we're just talking about
the Bible and the Quran Jesus being God
and the gospel message um so it's
actually interesting that you guys came
at the time that you did it's funny um
all right but the last when we were
talking to the uh to the missionaries um
or when I was talking to the
missionaries last time what we left off
was um like so I'm very scriptural right
I'm very biblically based so if
something is in the Bible I submit to it
if it's not in the Bible I don't right
make sense so um my thing was
about um because I I I I heard about
Joseph Smith teaching that this this
idea that um that you guys can become
Gods one day right and you and you guys
affirm this okay so for me I'm like okay
the Bible says that you know God is the
only God that there will be no God after
him right he knows not one so how can
you guys
reconcile you know that with the IDE
that there will actually be more Gods
later how do you guys like oh let me
just that
something you
guys well from what we believe is kind
of like you know what we believe is that
God has a plan for us and that we will
all be like him one day and that's kind
of what we learned from from the book
Mormon and also we learned from the
Bible from what I've seen is in like
First Corinthians 15 it talks about like
different teers of of Heaven kind of
and so that's kind of how I know that
you know we we'll live with God and that
we'll also become like him I mean if we
live with him then we're living the way
he does yeah so that's kind of how I've
seen it is when we live his law we
become just like him and it says in 1
Corinthians 15 from the from the King
James B it
says all flesh is not the same flesh but
there's one kind of Flesh of men another
flesh of beasts another another of
fishes and another Birds there are also
celestial bodies and bodies terrestial
but the glory of the celestial is one
and the glory of the terrestrial is
another there's one glory of the Sun and
another glory of the Moon and another
glory of the star for one star differeth
from another star in glory right right
so we just believe that there are
there's tears to to Like Heaven There
the celestial terrestrial and telestial
and Celestial since the sun brightest
would be where God is and if we all can
go back to where God lives and live his
laws then we would be Gods just like him
so so contextually it sounds like that's
talking about the different types of
bodies or glories that certain things in
creation has right and so you're saying
that there is a type of Glory that we
also will have as Believers there a type
of Glory that God has so my my question
is when you say that you know you'll be
like God meaning that you will also you
guys will will become as as he is divine
creating ability all knowing and stuff
like that yeah because we you know like
when we die it's not the end it's where
our our body and our Spirits because we
believe that we are all spirits that
we're here to gain a physical body and
when we die our physical body stays here
on Earth but our spirit goes to a place
like the spirit world and from there we
kind of learn and we learn more about
Jesus Christ we gain more faith and we
we move up right we just we continually
go until we're judged so but so but my
question is how how does that reconcile
if there's going to be Gods after God um
how does that reconcile with he when he
says that there will be no God after him
he says that he's the first and he's the
last if he's the if he's the first and
last there's no God before him or after
him how can there be Gods after him
you well yeah I mean like from The Book
of Mormon we learned that we will
inherit the kingdom of God I'm not too
sure where that is in the book more but
I know that it's in there that talks
about how we will inherit what he has
because we are all heirs to it alongside
our our brother Jesus Christ well that's
see that's I have no problem with us
inheriting the kingdom like the Bible
says that right this is you know we're
going to inherit the kingdom of God but
the problem comes when like to to say
that that we are becoming Gods like
that's that's the difference there like
we of course I'm going partake in God's
kingdom you know he's going to glorify
us as Believers but to say that we're
going to become Gods is is directly
against what he says when he says
there's not going to be any Gods after
him that that's that's what that's the
part that I'm I'm fixated on that's the
part I'm stuck on I can't it let me just
show you let me see if I could actually
pull it up yes like somewhere in Isaiah
he says
uh right here Isaiah Let's do let's do
let's do maybe
446 and then also do
48 uh 12 let's see what those
say let's see what the let's see what
they'll
say okay
yes so it says here so Isaiah
44:6 it says thus says the Lord king of
Israel um and his Redeemer the Lord of
hosts I am the first and I am the last
besides me there is no
God right and then uh 4812 he says the
same thing listen to me oh Jacob and
Israel whom I called I am he I am the
first and I am the
last all
right so if he's the if he's the last
then obviously there's no Gods that's
going to come after him so if somebody
is teaching that there's Gods that's
going to come after God then that is an
obviously anti-biblical teaching Goa you
you get what I'm coming from the the way
that I view it is there's a scripture I
don't remember exactly where it is but
we can send it to you after but it says
we'll be like God and I don't interpret
that as we will be God we'll just be
like him um so God has a perfect body of
Flesh and Bone and so after we get
resurrected we'll also have that perfect
body of Flesh and Blood now see that
right there I have no problem with
because it does say that we will we will
be like him and glorified in will we
share in that Glory right so when we are
resurrected to peress C our bodies will
be changed and our you know we'll move
from the physical to the spiritual from
the corruptible to The Incorruptible
we'll be perfect just like Jesus is when
he rose so that is biblical I totally
agree with that but if if somebody's
teaching that if someone's going beyond
that and saying that we actually become
Gods that's where I'll say okay you know
what that right there is a false doctor
because it's it's a good scripture you
know what I'm saying so
um I need to get the exact ref it's been
a long time since I looked into LDS but
it's I saw the reference and hopefully
next time we talk we can maybe go deeper
into it more information now that we
know what what we're talking about but
um um I want to get the reference
because if Joseph Smith is teaching that
we become gods and that like even that
God himself wasn't always God that he
also became God that that is just that's
anti-biblical and we have to call it
what it is if that's the case you know
so I got I got to double check myself I
ain't like smashing at all right now but
I gotta double check myself definitely
looking more into Isaiah
4812 and try to all I'll look into it
because we got to go soon but I mean
it's good to meet you talk a little bit
Yeah excited for the next time we can
can talk again for sure for sure for
sure yeah I'll walk you guys out man I I
appreciate you guys coming to sit with
me man oh yeah for sure hey say say bye
to the LDL ERS guys I appreciate
you hey D hold it down for me while I um
hold it down for me man